[Applause]
you don't want to do this
stop Clark this is over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
how can you be against me on this he
took Coast City think about Carol how
Brainiac asked to pay no Clark my rage
won't bring Carol back just like yours
could bring back Lois you shouldn't have
come back how I'm tired of fighting you
Arthur
that man knew they'd double-cross him we
have to move Cal stop these are your
friends my friends should be helping me
instead of standing in my way
[Music]
this is on you Barry when you defected
the regime fell you left us vulnerable
to Brainiac you shouldn't have lost your
nerve I lost my nerve when I didn't
stand up to you the first time Clark
never again stand up to that kal I can't
forgive you so easily this time Cara
there's still hope kal I know you're
afraid for everybody ever since you lost
Lois I used to be afraid afraid my
powers would make people fear me afraid
who I'd hurt if I wasn't careful every
second of every day I spent my whole
life holding back my fear cost me Lois
that's why I don't hold back anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she led us right to him it's no accident
you brought us here of course it isn't I
warned him about Diana but I didn't
believe you'd turn on me
[Music]
you should want Brainiac dead more than
anyone instead you're undermining me
they growl your father can't see you
when General Zod tried to take over
Krypton jor-el led the fight against him
that's who you come from that's who you
are kal not this if jor-el had been more
like Zod he might have saved Krypton I
will save the earth
I'm sorry your war is over fighting on
the same side it felt like old times but
I guess we both knew it would end this
way do you remember that night when you
told me Louis was pregnant you knew even
before I said anything that was a good
memory from another lifetime
I miss the people we were then
me too
yeah quit Bruce
you can't win you of all people know
Clark I never quit
it's over Bruce
you don't have to do this I'm not
letting Brainiac lived with the earth at
risk again then what I'm your next
victim
[Music]
I could have killed you years ago that
would have been so easy
so go ahead Clark do it show me what a
villain looks like is that what you want
to see
[Music]
he's still breathing
if he dies he dies a martyr I want him
kept alive we need to deal with Karl
she's young give her time she'll come
around and if she doesn't she will this
time everyone will
[Music]
[Music]
you bonded with Brainiac [ __ ]
Brainiac is dead the remaining cities
have been restored and just like I told
you
Earth is at peace under your heel I wish
you'd come around Cara I'm building a
new army to protect the earth there are
billions of warriors trapped in
brainiacs collection
Kryptonians daksa minds zarnian I'll
have a legion whose power rivals the
combined Lantern cores and I want you to
lead it with me never cow you'll either
make the right choice or I'll make it
for you
what's it going to be
[Music]
you